there is new polling that reveals the
priorities of Republican voters in 2024
and it is utterly and fundamentally
cuckoo for Cocoa Puffs the modern
American conservative movement
is focus on some really wild stuff CBS
News poll on how 2024 Republican
presidential primary race could be Trump
versus Trump fatigue this is this is
super interesting at this early stage of
the primary to the the CBS News article
reads to the extent the Republican
primary is a contest at all right now it
looks like it's one between Trump and a
sentiment one might call Trump fatigue
and Trump is winning that matchup easily
here's why Maga sounding ideas are
widely held in the Republican electorate
an environment that plays heavily to
Trump's Advantage there's big demand for
a candidate who says Trump won in 2020
who challenges woke ideas who doesn't
criticize Trump and for good measure
makes liberals angry Trump leads in all
of those areas meanwhile there are some
Republicans who say they're exhausted by
Trump and he's too controversial but
they are greatly outnumbered today check
this out
uh top answers from likely Republican
primary voters these are folks who based
on their answers have been categorized
as likely to vote in the primary primary
remember that's a critically important
detail uh 2024 Republican nomination
can't uh likely Republican primary
voters prefer a candidate who 85 percent
challenges woke ideas
oh boy
66 percent opposes any gun restrictions
say Trump won the 2020 election
and 57 percent makes liberals angry now
there are two layers within which this
is interesting the first layer is
Republicans for so long have been
insisting we care about issues of
importance to all Americans economic
issues jobs
inflation something like that we're
supposed to believe that's what they
care about when you look at the polls
the likely Republican primary voters
care about very different things the
most interesting part of this
is that
these interests
are likely to lead to a republican
candidate that is out of step with the
country as a whole let me explain what I
mean by that when Trump was arrested
and his approval went up among
Republican primary voters one of the
things we saw we surmised we noticed is
that while it is likely to help Trump in
the primary by energizing his base
because he's been treated so unfairly
you know the whole thing
um it's not likely to get him any new
votes in the general election and
similarly when we looked at Ron DeSantis
potentially running an anti-woke
campaign while that plays relatively
well with Republican primary voters when
you survey the country as a whole
wokeness for lack of a better term is
actually the more popular position and
similarly when you look at some of these
things if 85 percent of likely
Republican primary voters want a
candidate that challenges woke ideas but
roughly 57 to 60 percent of the country
sides with wokeness on trans issues and
on so many other issues you have a
scenario in which the person that
Republicans are most likely to select to
represent them in November of 2024 is
not actually the person most likely to
win that general election now this isn't
news to us when you look at polling that
does primary and then does hypothetical
general election match up you see Trump
does really well in the primary but
loses to Biden generally speaking on
average loses to Biden in the November
election so there's a few layers where
this is interesting one it confirms that
the not just Republicans in general
because you could be a republican who
plans to vote in November of 24 but
you're not engaged enough to vote in the
primary so this really is likely primary
voters the likely primary electorate of
the Republican Party
is very much out of step with the way
that the country as a whole is going
that's number one and then number two
we've said for a while now Republican
elected officials Republican candidates
better said have abandoned policy in
part because they're losing the country
on policy so instead they talk about
this sort of stuff let's do nothing on
guns let's fight wokeness let's ban
books Let's Stop drag shows whatever
else the case may be
that is in itself also not apparently a
winning ideology or a winning platform
they've lost on policy so they've
abandoned it and they've moved on to
cultural issues but they're also not
winning the cultural issues nationally
and yesterday we looked at how they're
losing on abortion and in other areas so
what are they to do
the answer is obvious it's what they've
been doing you try to win elections by
saying you won even if you lost and that
should really scare all of us because it
means they will almost certainly try it
again in 2024.